hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the melody I know that's
bad no that's wrong and I'm ashamed all
my French fans but I have a perpetual
quest to mispronounce II ate everything
that I say so here we go
this game I saw on SEO um it may seem
like just a normal platformer but you're
gonna see that it's just a little bit
bizarre compared to everything that
you've seen before in just a second
magnifique so the game um wait oh thank
you hey Mon well this is only this is a
look part of the madness that you're
about to see and then I'm gonna go to
the exhibit where it gets really bizarre
is what I imagine is gonna show me in
the next one unless there's something
else to it welcome to the restaurant
yes allow me to show you to your seat
and your weird mario block table don't
mind it at all hello sir hello welcome
I'm Elsie bit cuckoo bit male Seebeck
wha ah baguette an Eiffel Tower oh yeah
use the arrow keys to extend okay this
would go a little awry
yeah Oh God hi hurts
Wow and somehow getting your torso
through the doors enough to consider at
the end of the game press Q hurry to
contract you know like a normal mr.
DeWitt ah oh yeah how do i oh it looks
so horribly painful but he looks so
bored feels nice I'm sure ho ho ho ha
lotion keeps your skin supple and
stretchy just hang here by my neck for a
second don't mind me everybody you carry
on with your dinner I'm having a
careful time just resting up on this
ledge ow we could it's so silly mmm
exquisite oh no she keeps your skin soft
and supple it also sounds a lot like
farts but we French are too polite for
farts I'm chewing the boards and tasting
anybody's ever yeah oh yeah hello sir
can I show you to your tablet and or sit
oh well it is a predicament
maybe if I whoop set it verifies its
rest here I got a thing about this gotta
let the blood flow to my brain so that I
know what I'm gonna be able to do huh
think about it okay so I gotta grab him
it like this yeah that's how you do ha
ha ha
magnifique ah thank you I think I got so
much lotion lying around nothing
questionable about that no weirdness
happening here oh ho ho I missed hip
mall and Bowie yeah yeah yeah got it
oh is this what all the French people do
in their spare time I need some input
from my French fans because I'm a little
scared
at the implications of what this means
for French culture
what Dorie man I'll be here just a
moment
I gotta get everything else in order in
my life this mess with my brain because
number one vision man you skill that
humans have he sold his soul to be able
to be the greatest waiter in the world
just like spongebob he dumped everything
except this time he dumped all parts of
his soul oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well whatever
screw you I don't know what you killed
me but
very upset yeah I don't know how that
worked past [ __ ]
yep there we go yeah here we go
you'd say to these human beings with
normal non stretchy skin would have the
sense and wherewithal to just be able to
go to their friggin tables why they
gotta get metamorphic Jones over here
instead of their own dumbasses hip nope
if you've met their back a half fact up
yeah there we go yeah Dan step and foot
[ __ ] yep there we go shabam
you're welcome thank you I'm a bum it's
a little bizarre that the waiter before
being seated at your weirdly spaced out
table that isn't anywhere in the
restaurant where you would actually eat
food that you have to wait for your
waiter to run around the restaurant and
collect lotion just seems a little
questionable I mean I'm not one to
question a lot of things in life in fact
I live a very abnormal life so I don't
know I mean not this abnormal I'm not
stretching myself out with lotion every
night shut up ah hey on let me stuff my
face in here you [ __ ] let me go in
all right fine I'll see you sir yep oh I
fit like a glove even me knowing what I
know and doing the things that I've done
know that that's just a little bizarre
oh they they scoot up on your putt
that's awfully convenient I don't need
all this lotion I just wanted it to be
able to create the best shape possible
[ __ ] hello hi yeah yeah hello Syl may I
take your order excuse me sir
may I take your order please pretty
pretty please may I take your order oh
all we are merci
oh Claire Pierre aah Sacre master sir
sir sir I do believe you're being rude
I'm all
to have to ask you to Zack at the
premise yes all right have a good day
goodbye oh okay I think that's all I'm
gonna play this game you kind of get the
basic concept of this um but this game
is free you can play for yourself
there's a link down in the description
below have a ton of fun with it because
it's a totally ridiculous concept and
then maybe you can practice your French
to be better than I am so today I'm
gonna be playing some five games and
then getting those out the door if you
want to give me suggestion please give
and we now because I will actually be
able to read them and find out what you
want to see more of on the leave butter
it go
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye I said please
don't murder me in my sleep hey
boys